in this world and nothing can be certain
except death taxes and a new Call of
Duty game every year the leaks were true
and this time we're turning back the
clocks to world war two if you want to
see more for Call of Duty World War two
make sure to hit that subscribe button
but in the meantime here's everything we
know so far
you play as private Ronald read Daniels
the newest member of the u.s. first
Infantry Division also known as the
bloody 1st or the big red one you will
be accompanied by first lieutenant
Joseph Turner private first class Robert
Sussman and technical sergeant William
Pierson unlike previous Call of Duty
games you won't have health regen in the
campaign health regen has been a staple
of the series since Call of Duty 2 the
1st Infantry Division departed from the
u.s. in August 1942 shortly after the
United States entered the war and took
part in campaigns across Africa the
invasion of Sicily and ultimately the
invasion of Normandy however the game
will focus on events from 1944 to 1945
we still aren't totally sure of all the
battles we will be able to take part in
but sledgehammer has confirmed a few the
story will focus on the Western Front of
the European theater of war based on the
trailer it looks like d-day and the
invasion of Normandy will play a large
role in the campaign we will also see
the Battle of Hurtgen forest a bloody
conflict between the German and American
forces near the German Belgian border
and the Battle of the Bulge a surprise
attack orchestrated by the Germans near
France
judging by avid dog Activision released
it also looks like we could take part in
the Battle of the Endon throughout most
of the game you will play as private
Daniels however there are some sequences
where you'll players were so a French
resistance fighter unlike private
Daniels she is better trained and good
with a sniper rifle here's hoping we get
another sniper mission as good as all
Gil eat up this time around
Oh as you'd expect you'll have to dust
off some older weaponry time to throw
out your heartbeat sensors jetpacks and
weird technology that lets you rewind
time there were a few guns we spotted in
the trailer like the m1 grand the Luger
a flamethrower the grease gun and the
mg42 this being a world war 2 game
though there are a few guns we will most
likely see such as the 1911 handgun the
m1903 the m1 a1 and the Browning rifle
oh and helmets to the face ow
the vehicles are also of the era as for
tanks the trailer gives us a glimpse at
the Sherman tank
the Panzer 6 heavy and the Panzer Tiger
2 the aircraft's we see in the trailer
are the p-47 Thunderbolt fighters what
looks to be b-25 bombers the Junkers
also known as the Ju 87 dive bombers
these planes have propellers on their
landing gear that created a siren noise
when they dove down in order to terrify
ground troops you can even hear that
sound in the trailer sledgehammer hasn't
shared much information on the
multiplayer but it will have a
multiplayer social space which is a
first for the series a narrative based
war mode create a class and it sounds
like you can play as a woman finally
there will be a co-op mode which looks
to be nazi zombies based on a teaser
image the developer released Call of
Duty World War 2 launches on November
3rd 2017 if you want to hear what we
thought of it in a behind-closed-doors
session head on over to our YouTube
channel what are your thoughts on the
trailer are you ready to invade the
beaches of Normandy once again let me
know in the comments below and as always
thanks for watching
welcome to the bloody 1st you're a long
way from Texas farm boy
you
[Music]